good afternoon
to the entire audience i am patrick
martin i'm an associate professor at
north carolina a t state university in
greensboro north carolina
by training i am a cancer
i did my undergraduate work at virginia
union university in richmond virginia
once completing my bs in biology i
attended the university of virginia in
charlottesville virginia
and earned a phd in cell and molecular
biology
and at that point in time i was the
first african american to earn a phd in
cell and molecular biology from the
university of virginia
at that time once i completed university
of virginia i stayed at the university
of virginia and moved from the cell
biology department over to a clinical
department in pathology and began to
study
brain tumors or glioblastoma
multiforming and that's where i picked
up my cancer research experience and
since then i've been doing cancer
research at north carolina a t
today my talk will be entitled examining
the chemotherapeutic potential of rosip
rosa canina extracts and triple negative
breast cancer
in my laboratory we study aggressive
tumors and triple negative breast cancer
happens to be a very aggressive tumor or
aggressive cancer
and we study this by using
a lot of times we try to identify novel
components or compounds or in this case
bioactive compounds that can potentially
serve as chemotherapeutic or therapy to
known chemotherapeutic
known theo chemotherapeutic complexes
so breast cancer
is abnormal growth of breast tissues
and
in the most recent cancer facts and
figures information that's provided
by the american cancer society in 2019
breast cancer was the number one site
or the number one
site of cancers in females you can see
there in the top right uh about 30 of
all new cancers and females
in the from 2016 to 2019
were in the breast tissue
also if we look at estimated cancer
deaths
breast cancer is number two in estimated
cancer deaths and we're looking at the
red highlighting material in the bottom
right portion of the slot
in which uh we expect
over 40 000 close to 41 000 cancer
deaths
each year
and that makes up about 14 percent of
all cancer deaths
so as you can see
breast cancer is a major issue for uh
female health and it's definitely a
major issue when it comes to cancers as
they are related to females
triple negative breast cancer again if
you look
take a look at this in ethnic or racial
capacity
a lot of times we study cancers in our
laboratory that have health disparities
and triple negative breast cancer is one
of those cancers that has a health
disparity
as you can see here um
about
32 percent of breast cancers in
african-americans
are
32 percent of cancers
deaths amongst african-americans in this
case is 19 of the deaths compared to 14
percent when you look at the entire
population
so triple negative breast cancer is a
it demonstrates a health disparity
against african american females as well
as hispanic
nationality
females as well as native americans and
americans
in addition to this health disparity
african american women have a lower
five-year survival rate
which is 81
compared to 92 percent among
non-hispanic white women
why is there such a difference in
survival rates
uh it's anticipated that there could be
biological genetic differences
prevalence or risk factors barriers to
health care excess or later stage of
breast cancer diagnosis
one of the reasons why we think there is
a health disparity is because of the
fact that triple negative breast cancer
which we will explain in more detail
going forward
is more
you see it more likely uh in
african-american females than you do in
other ethnicities
we can see here uh
if you look at just breast cancer you
have a non-triple negative
subtype and then you have a triple
negative subtype which is highlighted in
the red box
the specific characteristics of triple
negative breast cancer that it lacks
three known receptors for breast health
those are the estrogen receptor
the progesterone receptor
and the her2 receptor or the human
epidermal growth factor receptor
this makes triple negative breast cancer
much more difficult to treat
because close to 80 percent of your
therapeutic options for breast cancer
are targeted to either the estrogen
receptor the progesterone receptor
or the her2 receptor
negative breast cancer again is an
aggressive form of breast cancer it's
highly metastatic it's migratory it's
invasive has a much poorer prognosis
than other forms of breast cancer
there are very few treatment options and
you have a lower recovery rate
in african american women we see triple
triple negative breast cancer more
in premenopausal women than we do in
other age groups
and also we see a higher prevalence in
pre-pre-menopausal women amongst
african-americans than any other ethnic
or racial group
and we have a higher occurrence rate of
recurrence for triple negative breast
cancer in african americans which is
close to 40 percent whereas in the
normal population not african-american
population is 15
so again
what makes triple negative breast cancer
triple negative
so
what you see is
that
your normal
treatments herceptin and tamoxifen
are made against the estrogen receptor
the her
her2 receptor and as well as the
progesterone receptor but in this case
in triple negative breast cancer
as you can see here in the yellow cell
on the right of the screen
it
doesn't have any of these receptors
so if we try to use
any of these
treatments against it
they are not effective because the
tamoxifen and herceptin do not have a
receptor to bind to so they can be
internalized into the cell and elicit
their effect so triple negative breast
cancers are very challenging once
diagnosed because they're very hard to
treat
in addition one of the major things that
we see with triple a triple negative
breast cancer is one of its major
characteristics its ability to migrate
and invade
uh throughout the breast tissue and
eventually external to the breast to
other organs and organ systems this
makes triple negative breast cancer and
any other cancer much more difficult to
treat once it metastasizes and leaves
its
host tissue or its initial host tissue
and we see that approximately
15 to 30 percent of triple negative
breast cancer patients actually develop
brain test metastases which are very
difficult to treat and the life
expectancy after metastasis is about 3
3 months to close to 24 months
so again just typical breast cancer
treatments you your first line of
defense is probably some type of surgery
whether it's mastectomy or some type of
lumpectomy
you can also do targeted radiation
chemotherapeutic which is uh would be
whole body chemotherapeutic there are
some hormone therapies that we could
target
for the estrogen receptor in the
progesterone receptor therapy such as
herceptin which can lead to
targeting
the her2
receptor
however all of these taken together are
not that effective in triple negative
breast cancer so it lends to the fact
that we need to find better ways to
treat this very aggressive form of
breast cancer
so this led to
a new
wing it's not really a new arm we've
been doing it probably for about close
to 10 years now in the department where
we look at natural therapeutics and
their ability to potentially serve as a
chemotherapeutic chemo preventative or
adjunct therapy
to known chemotherapeutic options so why
don't we look at chemo chemotherapeutics
from natural products
one they typically have lowerable
unfavorable side effects than
chemotherapy and they typically have a
low low toxicity
and they typically have a low much lower
cost than some of our synthesized
medicines
um
natural therapies uh help provide
antioxidant foods
which may be
have an improvement for cancer treatment
and additionally a lot of your natural
products have flavonoids and carotenoids
which have been demonstrated to be
effective in preventing
various forms of cancer including breast
cancer
so what we began to focus on
serendipitously is uh rosehip or rosa
canina extracts and it just so happened
i was on a committee when i first got to
north carolina and t
and a student in the agricultural
department was doing a master's degree
looking at
potential natural chemotherapeutics
and i was invited on the committee and
so i served on the committee and i began
to say well it is great that you have
this empirical data but we need to
really begin to test it
more succinctly and in
known methods
in that time we were looking at a brain
and liver cancer but now we focused on
triple negative breast cancer
so rose hips which i typically call them
or rosa canina
they're actually formed from
what we call the easter rose it's the
type of rose that buzz around easter
time each year as we're entering in
spring from winter have a high level of
vitamin c and other vitamins
high levels of calcium iron and zinc
and as well as lycopene which can be
found in tomatoes and grapefruit which
is also shown anti-tumor properties
common names for the uh rose tip are dog
rose or wild rose
it's commonly used as a natural
supplement to relieve pain such as
arthritic pain menstrual pain intestinal
pain
colds flu sore throats it's found in
many teas you actually find it in a lot
of health and beauty aids such as face
lotions as well
some previous work done
in
several laboratories have demonstrated
that rosehip tea or extracts from
rosehip can prevent breast cancer cell
proliferation
and additionally it can decrease
abdominal visceral fat in pre-obese
subjects
previously we've published
the effect of these roship extracts on
human brain tumor cell proliferation in
apoptosis and we've uh basically
demonstrated that concentrations of
these roasted extracts can slow down and
decrease the proliferation rate
of malignant brain tumor cells
and we're going to do some of that work
here in triple negative breast cancer
so overall what are we trying to focus
on in this study or this these studies
that i'm going to show you today
we want to determine the potential
roasted extracts as a regular regulator
of cell proliferation migration
and invasion of triple negative breast
cancer cells
today we're really going to focus here
on just objective number one is to
determine the effect of roasted extracts
on cell proliferation migration and
invasion in breast cancer cells
we're also going to determine if roasted
extracts can serve as an adjuvant
therapy with a commonly known breast
cancer therapeutic agents to induce
apoptosis
so we have these roasted extracts and
we're going to expose them to human
breast cancer cell lines and we're going
to focus mainly on
in the list there from top to bottom
hcc 1500
which are a breast cancer cell line they
are technically not triple negative but
they are an aggressive form of luminal
breast cancer
hcc70 i will refer to these as 70s going
forward i'll refer to the 1500s since
1500s going forward and then finally hcc
1806's
a triple negative breast cancer we also
will talk about briefly the
ag-11132s this is a normal breast tissue
cell line that we always try to run in
our study
when we look into this chemotherapeutic
so one of the first things we do we'll
do an mtt assay
we'll do apoptosis cleavage assay
um to determine whether or not we're
having an effect on cell proliferation
and whether or not we're promoting
apoptosis with rosehip extracts
so typically most of our assays
cell-based assays are done in a 96 well
plate
uh you can see here that we will have uh
our controls our serum starved we have
serum containing or plus serum we have a
known inhibitor of the
um of the mtor pi3 kinase pathway
ly294002 we have a known inhibitor of
the erc pathway
u0126 and then we have our rosip uh
extracts which are developed in uh there
their methanol-based extracts
and they are one milligram per ml 250
microgram per meal 25 microgram per meal
and 25 nanogram per ml
so the first thing we do we did an mtt
assay in which we just basically asked
the question
um do we see a decrease in mitochondrial
activity which we associated with a
decrease in proliferation
if you look at the three figures here
you have the 1806s the 70s and then the
1500s
and if you notice on a and b in both of
these a is your minus serum control then
the b labeled
bar is your plus serum control this is
basically our control with minus serum
we're serum starving the cells so they
should not grow much and then we'll give
them a serum stimulation the plus serum
to ask the question do the cells go
ahead and grow
then we begin to treat with um
an order from higher concentration to
lower concentration with your relative
extracts and what we notice here if you
look at all of the um
bars labeled c
is that our highest concentration of
roasted extracts is able to decrease
the amount of cell proliferation in all
of the cell lines
tested
and again we can have some decrease as
well in lower concentrations such as 250
microgram per ml 25 microgram per meal
and 25 nanogram per meal
so this was pretty uh interesting for us
to see that we actually can start with
these roasted extracts um
expose them to the cells and we expose
them to the cells for 48 hours and then
we ask the question do they slow or stop
cell proliferation and we can see here
there's a dose-dependent effect that we
can decrease cell proliferation at the
highest concentration we actually
stop cell proliferation so we're pretty
excited about this this is our first
foray
into the triple negative breast cancer
treatments with the roads of extracts
so we know roasted extracts can decrease
cell proliferation but the next thing
you always think about if these are
chemotherapeutic can they also promote
apoptosis and kill these cancer cells so
the next assay we're going to look at
we're going to ask the question can we
actually
kill or
initiate apoptosis in these triple
negative breast cancer cells
so what you have here
again you have uh at the top left you
have 1806 cell ons uh just next to that
you have uh hcc70 cell lines and at the
bottom center you have the 1500 cell
lines
and what we're showing in this diagram
you have a two lines you have a line
that has um
circles and a line that has triangles
the circle line is this looking at cell
viability so that's akin to our mtt
assay
whereas the triangle line is looking at
caspase-37 cleavage
which is
an indicator of apoptosis in these cells
so
we're looking at cell viability on the
y-axis on the left
and on the right y axis we're looking at
caspase cleavage so when we get caspase
cleavage we know that we're entering
apoptosis along the bottom we're looking
at
our different treatment groups with plus
serum on the far left
then we move into one milligram per meal
of rose hip 250 micrograms per ml of
rosehip and then 25
microgram for male roses and 25
nanograms per meal and finally on our
far right on each one of those graphs we
have
one micromolar store sporing this is a
um
it elicits it's a chemical compound that
can elicit apoptosis in these cells so
it is a what we call apoptosis positive
control
so what we can see here in 1806 is that
as you're going along if you look at
that top line there
uh when you treat with the plus serum
and all the roasted
uh you have the cells are pretty viable
so they're not dying when we treat them
with rosehip but if you look um
and if you look at the line at the
bottom of the graph you can see that
that's measuring cast basically
so again
when caspase is clearly
in caspase cleavage uh in 1806 cells
when we
treat with star sporing
we actually
uh can induce apoptosis in the cells and
you can see that the top line uh drops
as far as cell viability close to 40 to
50
and the amount of caspase cleavage goes
up to close to 100 percent
uh if you look at acc 70s and hcc 1500s
you see very similar trends in the line
there in which eurozip extract is not
killing the cells it is not promoting
death it is only merely stopping the
cell from growing uh it's inhibiting
cell proliferation but not killing the
cells if you look at the western blot
over there to the right
we have uh
hcc 1806s then 70s and 1500s and
basically we're asking a question are we
cleveland park
park along with cats based cleavage are
signs of apoptosis and if you can look
there at all the treated samples only
the
column on the far right which is
actually treated with your store sporing
you can actually see part being cleaved
and part uncleaved is 116 kilodaltons
and cleaved it is 89 kilodaltons
so
as you can see that
the take home from this is that yes
rosehip
uh extracts can stop these cells from
growing
but they don't kill the cells they're
merely cytostatic and not cytotoxic
so relative extracts decrease cell
proliferation all the cell lines without
inducing apoptosis
erosive extracts neither stimulate part
cleavage nor activation of caspase-37 in
human breast cancer cell lines so what's
next we know we can stop these cells
from growing but we're not killing the
cell so
and we're happy that we can slow the
cells and stop them from growing but
we're not killing them so we next want
to ask the question what's the next
biggest thing with uh breast cancer it's
the metastasis the migration invasion
can we slow or stop these cells from
migrating and invading
so the next thing we want to do is
actually answer these questions so
initially we'll look at migration on the
left here you'll see little uh
it's a
cell plate with six wells in each plate
and we have two little red lines and
basically what we do we culture these
cells with a plunger in the middle
and we eventually pull that plunger up
and that leaves a void and we ask the
question do cells can cells crawl into
that void and if so we know they're
migrating
and additionally we did a hanging
well very similar to a transwell except
for this time we just ask and the cells
crawl the three-dimensional
uh metrics more so than a
two-dimensional matrix
so the first thing we did we looked at
hcc 1806 cells
uh we culture the cells regularly on the
six uh well plate
uh the black space is the void the green
is the pseudo color we added to actually
quantify the amount of cell
uh migration and as you can see here we
have zero hour at the top and 24 hour at
the bottom
and basically what we are looking at
here we're asking a question from 0 to
24 does that black space get smaller
you can see with minus serum it doesn't
much plus serum it definitely does and
then we use our treatments at one
milligram and 250 micrograms per mil
we're able to decrease that migration
significantly almost stop it completely
with the lower concentrations 25
micrograms per meal and 25 nanograms per
ml the cells still move and move almost
as well as the controls
so again rosehip at higher
concentrations can at least block the
migration of these cells
we next looked at hcc 70s and we see a
very similar
event going on
plus serum cells go ahead and grow
fairly well
with the higher concentrations of
rosehip you're able to stop the cells
from migrating with the lower
concentrations you're getting some some
migration there almost similar to what
we see in our plus serum controls
the next thing
we see
is um
we're taking a look here at
htc 1500 cell lines
and again very similar plus serum they
go ahead and um
crawl together
and uh in the higher concentrations of
your
rosehip
extracts they don't crawl as well so
again very similar we're able to
we're able to
determine at this point in time that
roasted extracts can prevent migration
so the next thing we wanted to do
is look at migration
okay so what we're looking at here we
did a hanging well assay and we asked
the question can the cells crawl
through a three-dimensional matrix
it's a
little paper membrane with holes in it
and can they crawl through and fall to
the bottom and if they can fall to the
bottom we know the cells are migrating
so that's exactly what we're asking for
here
so
what we're doing here we took the same
thing 1806s hcc7 these and hcc 1500s and
you can see from left to right you have
no treatment one milligram per ml
rosehip and 25 microgram per meal
of hip so we have a high concentration
and a lower concentration
and what you can notice there is in that
middle column with the high
concentration you're able to stop the
amount of cells that can migrate through
in a 24 hour period
um
you can see the same thing you can see
some inhibition as well with 25
micrograms per mil of rosehip and then
those graphs on the side actually do a
quantification of this and we can see
that we have significant inhibition of
migration
and all three cell lines tested and we
actually have that with the higher
concentration and the lower
concentrations of rotation
so this point in time we're pretty happy
we can stop the cells from growing
we can stop the cells from migrating so
the next thing we want to ask the
question is can we stop them from
invading so we use the same
transwell or hanging well assay we had
that paper
lining again with the holes in it this
time we coated the top part of that with
the extracellular matrix membrane and we
asked the question can these cells
degrade that extracellular matrix
membrane crawl through the holes and
fall to the bottom
if this is so we know the cells have the
ability to metastasize they can actually
leave the breast tissue get into the
bloodstream or lymphatic scene
lymphatic vessels and move throughout
the body and this will mimic this is an
in vitro
imitation of metastasis
so we did the same thing very similar
we looked at rosehip extracts again you
have uh hcc 1806
70s and 1500s from top to bottom
three columns once again
no treatment
one milligram per meal and 25 microgram
per ml and this time we
let the cells go for 48 hours because we
need to have them timed to see if they
could actually degrade the extracellular
matrix
and again what we notice that although
it's not as apparent as the migration
but the higher concentration
dip one mig per mil can actually slow
down the ability of these cells to
migrate and invade so
we know we can stop the cells rosehip
from growing we know we can stop their
migration and we can slow their invasion
down as well so it has potential to be a
fairly good chemotherapeutic agent
so
we looked at our objective one where
demonstrating erosive can block growth
can block migration and can slow
invasive migration in the breast cancer
cell
so what's next well the one thing we
want to do is ask a question
we understand people are hesitant about
taking natural products but can we use
the natural products in combination with
a known chemotherapeutic
agent to see if you
can center have synergistic effects and
better the effects of both roasted
extracts as well as the
known chemotherapeutic agent
so we actually use doxorubinson you can
see it here
um
basically uh it's known it's a tip top
it's a drug that's commonly used to
treat breast
breast cancer and it commonly treats
triple negative breast cancer as well
has a high amount of toxicity to
non-cancerous cells as well
and previous studies have shown that
quercetin
another natural product along with dr
rubinson can actually have synergistic
effects
in reducing breast cancer cell growth
and also decreasing some of the toxicity
of doxorubicin
so what we want to do is ask the
question if we combine roship and
doxorubicin together
can we decrease cell proliferation even
further
and can we also begin to
promote
cleavage which is a sign of apoptosis so
the grafts at the top again are 1806
and 1500's from left to right
and the one thing i really want you to
focus on is the far right column on each
graph that's where we use rosehip and
doxorubicin together
and in all those cases it has a
synergistic effect to reduce the amount
of proliferation even further
alone you can see the one mig per ml
rosehip and the 20 micromolodox rubinson
which are
the third and fourth columns in each
graph respectively
they
they can reduce cell proliferation to
below
baseline levels but together when you
combine them in the final column they
actually reduce proliferation even
further
and if you can look at the western blots
what we can also see
is that they are actually beginning to
24 hours and somewhat at eight hours the
combination of rose hip and doxyroofs
and begin to show parp cleavage so
together they're synergizing to not only
inhibit cell proliferation but also
begin to promote apoptosis which rosehip
extracts were not allowed were not able
to do on their own
we also decided to look at these in
combination and migration experiments
again we have 1806 and 70 cells zero
hours at the top 24 hours at the bottom
and again if you look at the far right
column you can see that together rosehip
and dox rooms and
are able to decrease cell migration uh
greater than they are as individual
agents and we've quantified that in the
grass to the right
and we can see the same
data with the 1500 cells we actually see
that rosehip and doxorubicin alone work
well in inhibiting migration in these
cells and together you don't see a huge
synergistic effect
so together
our conclusions are the erosive extracts
decreased cell proliferation migration
migration and invasion of these triple
negative breast cancer cell lines
they do not promote apoptosis and breast
cancer cell lines
however together rose hip extracts
synergize the doctor rheumatoid to
inhibit cell proliferation and begin to
promote apoptosis
and doxorubicin and the combination of
roasted extracts prevent cell migration
in breast cancer cell lines
so finally with the
little time i have left we always like
to ask this question and every time we
try to publish something
reviewers always ask
well what's the effect of these rose sip
extracts on normal breast cells
are you killing those as well
erosive extracts although they're a
natural product are they going to have
the same cytotoxic effects on normal
non-cancerous cells
so we are fortunate enough that we have
some breast
stem cells and they're really just
breast cells
and we can run
these sorts of assays so again we
right here we ran a cell proliferation
assay
um
in the middle there we're looking at
part cleavage with the and these are the
one three ag-11132 cell line which is
our normal breast cell line
and we just wanted to ask a question
derosiv extracts prevent
uh the proliferation of these normal
non-cancer cell lines and do they also
begin
to promote apoptosis
so in the left graph there you see that
higher concentrations of roasted extract
can decrease
cell proliferation in this normal breast
cell line however if we look at the
western blot there the middle western
blot
uh which looks at park cleavage we only
see park cleavage in the far right
column
suggesting that rosehip
extracts just as they did in the cancer
cells do not promote apoptosis in the
normal breast cells so we're pretty
happy to see that they can slow the
growth of the normal breast cells
similar to that what they do in cancer
cells however they don't promote
apoptosis which is good for
cytotoxic side effects
so
just to try to wrap up in the overall
conclusions rose hip extracts inhibit
cell proliferation migration and
invasion without promoting apoptosis
these extracts synergize with dr
rubinson to inhibit cell proliferation
promote apoptosis and prevent cell
migration
roses af rosic rose hip extracts do not
kill
normal breast cells they merely delay
their proliferation
and in conclusion i'd just like to
acknowledge
most of this the people who did this
work uh patrice cagle
uh she did
uh close to 80 to 90 of this work when
she was a phd student in my laboratory
uh she is now a postdoc
associate at a at north carolina central
university
patrice did exceedingly well she
published three papers she was able to
win a nsf graduate research fellowship
award
before she moved on to her post-doc
adamoli shofaloy he did some of the
initial triple negative breast cancer
cell migration experiments
uh he is now finishing up his residency
at emory university as an orthopedic
surgeon
and is the chief orthopedic surgery
resident at emory
currently and has already got a
fellowship for ankle and foot surgery
others we've collaborated to help us
look at some of the bioactive components
of rosehip
as well as we'd like to thank dr keith
schimmel who at that point in time was
the director of the phd program and dr
saran who at that point time was dean of
the graduate college they really helped
us in seeking our funding and making
sure patrice had the funding she needed
to be successful this work was supported
by a title iii program
it was supported by the national science
foundation graduate research fellowship
program to patrice as well as a nih
bridges to doctor program that i serve
as the pi of and nsf alliance for
graduate education program that i serve
at the pio
and
i would like to thank everybody
and open the floor for questions right